A few months ago, I was joined
here in my backyard by Dr.
James Grime, and he was
planting a sunflower
here in this pot.
It was all part of a big
national project, and I'll put
some information in the
link under the video.
But now, I'm pleased to
reveal the sunflower.
Grown up, no thanks to
me, I have to say.
But we are having a
bit of a problem.
You see, we've been counting
the seeds here in the head.
It's all to do with
Fibonacci numbers.
I'm sure you've all
heard it before.
And we did one count, and we
came up with 34 spirals.
And that's a Fibonacci number.
That's what we were expecting.
But when we counted the other
way, we keep coming up with 54
spirals, and not 55.
It should be 55, because that's
the Fibonacci number.
It is really hard counting seeds
in the head of a flower.
And maybe we're doing
it wrong.
So I'm actually asking some of
you guys to go and have a look
into our count for us to
see what you think.
I'm going to put a nice, big,
detailed picture of that on my
blog and on Flickr.
And I'll put links
under the video.
So go and have a look, do
a bit of a count, and
see what you think.
Is this not a Fibonacci
sunflower?
Or are we just a bit rubbish
at counting the spirals?
Get in touch.
See what you reckon.